once the customer decides on the colors
we make a blend and then we cut the
fiber this after cutting we stick it
over to the paper machine we take it
over here and it goes to the car we
bring the fiber over here they can on
this table and then it flicks it on to
the vacuum and that's how we make
fabulous fur
hey Fred hey there
all right thank you these pitiful we
have them here in front of us thank you
so much for doing that
tell me about which ones we're looking
at though the ones that we liked the
best were CF 205 7-1 XL and 205 7-0 and
so yeah those are our favorites as well
are those custom blends or of course
they are that's why they look so good if
you turn it upside down you'll get a lot
more loft out of it without the weight
we like the darker ones all right so we
all agree that it's spell that we're
gonna yeah yep busy cutting away okay
fantastic
thank you so much
this is great it's great material it's
very forgiving as a person
so we we can machine such this seems we
don't have to pick them out because they
were so long and it stretches so
the pant leg which is being cut out is
going to come all the way down here
and it's going to be seen to eat and
it's going to glue
ed told me where he wanted the pattern
to be he cut up the hair
Tracy and I glued the entire edge and
then I basically just went off
50 is great especially if you have mass
quantities and area to do any any
creature that involves a large suit
or it's any
if you were to hand tie it
a large crew at least
put a little covariant you know like how
I have no I just show it keep my toe
hairs really look at him it's gonna be
like this basically
Oh judge a little bit of product you
know one of the really cool things about
working directly with nft is that Kim
and Fred were able to give us insider
tips and tricks on how to make for a
look great the air has been so great for
us we usually don't get to participate
in the end result this has been fabulous
all your hard work
you can getting us involved in the
beginning
great thing for us check out the wired
channel the scene calm for the entire
giant creature series